in this video we'll talk about the
principles of fluorescence microscopy
as the name suggests this microscopy
employs the principle of fluorescence
for imaging
so
to begin with we need a fluorescently
labeled specimen
we can use the technique of
immunohistochemistry to label our
specimen in this case we have a nuclear
antigen which we can label with a
primary antibody and then a fluorophore
coded secondary antibody
also
we can express some of our
fluorescently labeled proteins or gfp
labeled proteins in a particular cell to
visualize a particular structure or
where they localize
anyway moral of the story is we need a
fluorescent specimen to begin with now
let's focus on the light path
so the light comes from a lighthouse
which might be a
mercury arc lamp which can also be
a led source
anyway
the light passes through this filter
cube
and then it gets diverted
to the specimen
through this objective lens
and it is focused on the specimen via
this objective lens
and inside the specimen there are
fluorophores so it would be excited and
the electrons would jump from ground
state to the excited state
eventually it would be relaxing
and ultimately leading to the emission
of fluorescence the fluorescence light
also travels through the objective pass
through the dichroic mirror and
ultimately get collected to the detector
or it forms the image in our retina in
case we are visualizing it with our eyes
anyway let's look at
the excitation and absorption spectrum
for this illumination in this case we
have illuminated our specimen with a
blue light and our specimen had gfp
expression in these cells
so there would be a fluorescence which
is corresponding to the green wavelength
and the emission spectral looks like
this green wave this spectrum
now
this emitted light has a higher
wavelength than the excitation light
because there is a energy loss during
these vibrational relaxation so
obviously the fluorescent emission has a
lower
energy that means a higher wavelength
and this shift is known as the stoke
shift
now let's look at the filter cube in bit
more details
we have excitation
excitation filter dichroic mirror and
emission filter
in the filter cube that directs the
light in specific orientation and
direction
so let's look at the microscope anatomy
to understand the light path in a better
fashion so the light is generated in the
lighthouse and it is passing through the
filter cube
and ultimately getting
getting to the specimen via the
objective
by changing the filter wheel we can
change the light sources into different
wavelengths such as in this case green
or even red
now let's focus on the blue light
because our specimen had gfp in that so
our illumination light is basically blue
so after excitation the fluorescence
which is emitted would be passing
through the objective and ultimately it
would pass through couple of mirror and
prism ultimately it would come to our
eyes and former image in the retina or
it could be also channeled towards the
detector like a camera
and we can see the fluorescence image of
the cells in this case a cytosolic gfp
is expressed in the cells so the whole
cell looks pretty much green
actually
a microscope has a array of filter q
that means there are more than one
filter cube
present in a filter will kind of set up
in the microscope by rotating this
filter way we can select our wavelength
of illumination
of the specimen we can illuminate gfp
rfp or whatever fluorescent molecule we
like so filter cubes are really
essential part of a fluorescence
microscope
now let's look at the application of
fluorescent microscopy in biomedical
research and then we can look at the
application in the clinical research
so first we can study several
subcellular localization of a protein
using fluorescent microscope in this
case we can tell that firstly the
protein
in the left is expressed on the cell
membrane secondly the protein was
localized in the
in the nucleus and the third it was
localized in the mitochondria we can
also use this kind of technique for
visualization of the specimen in real
time under fluorescence microscope and
this is known as live imaging let's say
we want to look at the fusion dynamics
of mitochondria
so mitochondria are is labeled with a
particular
protein which has a mitochondrial
localization signal and it is gfp tag so
the mitochondria is now fluorescing we
can track its dynamics over time
and we can see how it has fused with
each other
so this is only possible with live
imaging and this is a big advantage
because biological processes are dynamic
like this cell moving from one end of
the tissue space to the another end and
this is really important for
developmental biologist who wants to
look at coordinated cell migration
during development
also
biology is all about motion so looking
at how vesicles are trafficked from the
cell body to the synapses is one of the
criteria that neurobiologists use
so
neurobiologists track the vesicle motion
through this new axons
so there are specific transporters which
would take these vesicles
and they would
take them to the synapses now if we
label the vesicle by some means we can
actually look at the motion of these
vesicles and
calculate several parameters such as
movement time scale movement kinetics
movement direction etc
now neurobiologists also used specific
calcium sensors
to record the neuronal activity in real
time
or to look at how neurons are responsing
to a particular stimuli that means
fluorescence microscopy can be
used for a wide variety of biomedical
research
now there are certain disadvantages of
fluorescent microscope first of all the
image that are produced in fluorescence
microscope is generally blurry
photo bleaching of the specimen is a big
problem
and the cells
which are under investigation in a live
imaging paradigm they might get
damaged
by prolonged exposure with that high
intensity light
so there could be photo damage of the
cells as well
now poor signal to noise ratio is
another problem
majority of the cases the fluorescence
microscope shows very high background
and there is a reason behind it in a
moment i'll discuss that
but photo bleaching is the biggest
disadvantage of fluorescence microscopy
and
when photo bleaching happened the
fluorescence is kind of lost permanently
now let's talk about the resolution of
the microscope which can be determined
with the help of this formula d equal to
lambda divided by 2 mu sine alpha or 2n
a now if this is the cell and this is
the objective and this is the light
which is illuminating the cell then the
half angle through the optical axis is
known as alpha and lambda is the
wavelength of the illumination light
and mu is basically the
refractive index of this media
if we plug in all these value we would
get a value of d and d is basically the
minimum distance between two points to
be told to be considered as resolved in
the first case we can see the points are
well resolved in second case they are
barely dissolved and the last case they
are unresolved
now all the disadvantages of
fluorescence microscopy can be overcomed
by other fluorescence microscopy
modification techniques such as confocal
microscopy which is kind of like a
upgradation of fluorescence microscopy
if you want to learn more about confocal
microscopy you can click on this link in
the i button it would take you to the
video
now
in fluorescence microscopy the biggest
problem is due to the wide field
illumination
so white field illumination means like
we are
illuminating the whole specimen all at a
time
let me give you this example in a better
fashion so cell is a 3d entity right
let's say there are fluorophores present
all over the cellular cytoplasm
and we are illuminating majority of
these fluorophores but where are we
recording from we are kind of capturing
one particular plane
so once we capture fluorescence from one
particular plane the force or the
fluorescence correspond to other planes
can also contaminate the fluorescence or
they can lead to a high background
and that is the biggest reason why we
get a lot of background in
immunofluorescence microscopy
now
in biomedical research and clinical
application we can use
immunofluorescence let's talk about the
i mean let's talk about the overall
importance in biomedical research but
let me tell you that even if bloody
images are produced in the fluorescence
microscope still this technique is
invaluable for clinical research
techniques like anti-nuclear antigen
test or ana test which is done to detect
presence of auto antibodies or to
confirm whether a patient has a
autoimmune disorder requires the
technique of indirect immunofluorescence
here specific fluorescence pattern
allows the pathologist to understand
whether anti
nuclear antibodies are present or not
also
other kind of diseases like bolas
pemprigoid and pempregas vulgaris all
these skin diseases can be detected by
performing immunofluorescence technique
so in clinical aspect as well
immunofluorescence and fluorescence
microscopy is really important if you
want a detailed video on that you can
click on the i button to get it
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can fund my channel by
patreon or via bim upi app if you are a
indian viewer you can use my qr code for
paying
your small contribution means a lot for
me
my courses are also present in an
academy you can use my code ap 10 to get
a 10 discount as usual don't forget to
like share and subscribe thank you